sometimes all it takes is one terrifying
moment to elevate a horror movie from
flash-in-the-pan fun to a must-see movie
a single scene can make the difference
between a movie that comes and goes
without much fanfare and one that makes
its way into cinematic history these
films managed to make moments that are
not only unforgettable but ones which
viewers might not be so eager to revisit
elevator down ty West modern horror
masterpiece the house of the devil is a
quiet tense film right up until its
infamous ending the movie surrounds
Samantha a babysitter who reluctantly
agrees to keep an eye on a couple's
bedridden mother predictably the night
doesn't quite go as planned but while
the film as a whole is suspenseful and
masterful in its building of tension
it's the finale that makes it all pay
off a spectacularly terrifying satanic
ritual and chase scene featuring blood
guts and the reveal of a horrific Lee
deformed grandmother the matriarch of a
devil worshipping cult the end is
relentless it hits the viewer like a
freight train and doesn't slow its
momentum for a second you'll be out of
breath by the time it's over and likely
not anxious to revisit it anytime soon a
close shave Eli Roth tends to excel at
nausea-inducing moments largely
involving gore mutilation and while his
filmography is chock-full of gut
churning nastiness there's something
about the brutal simplicity of his debut
film cabin fever the scene in question
involves one of the characters shaving
her legs the catch while the plot of the
movie revolves around some 20-somethings
in the woods who are exposed to a
flesh-eating virus
so as she shaves her legs her flesh is
peeling from the bone piece by piece
it's both repulsive and enthralling and
you'll probably never want to watch it
again
discovering the tapes few scary movies
have utilized sound scares quite as well
as the psychological horror juggernut
session 9 the film takes place in an
abandoned mental asylum and shows how
the lingering spirits affect a group of
men who are there to refurbish the
building one of the men Mike discovers a
cache of tape recordings of therapy
sessions with a patient suffering from
dissociative identity disorder who might
also be possessed these tapes play
throughout the film but it's that first
scene that stands out as the film's
creepiest moment the squeal of the tape
the moment the voices appear everything
about it is masterfully executed as soon
as the voices start
the viewer knows something is wrong
something bad is going to happen as the
sessions move closer and closer to the
titular session nine Mary the scene
doesn't jump out at you
it doesn't feature a gory dismemberment
but it's creepy to the point that
viewers will want to avoid it upon any
future revisiting of the film the sloth
David Fincher's seven features a number
of gruesome mutilations but choosing its
standout doesn't feature dismemberment
or decapitation it simply features a man
left to rot the film's villain had
chained the victim for a year and simply
never let him move doing just enough to
keep him alive for a long enough time to
allow his body to waste away the makeup
is horrifying creating an image of a man
who looks like something other than
human it's a nauseating sight to behold
which is exactly what it should be and
it's all capped off with the reveal that
the victim is still alive in a film full
of horrific imagery and dark plot turns
the sloth victim is the hardest moment
to endure more than once it doesn't have
a tense narrative turns of the film's
grim ending it doesn't need to it's
horrifying enough on premise alone night
vision the descent is an exercise and
unrelenting horror and while the whole
film may be difficult to dive into more
than once
the night vision scene in particular is
almost too terrifying to screen twice
the film features a group of friends on
a caving trip who find themselves hunted
by a group of cave-dwelling mutants the
film does a great job of keeping the
creatures hidden until the perfect
moment already thriving in
claustrophobia and fear of the dark the
film switches to the point of view of
one of the women as she uses her
camcorders night vision feature her gaze
jolts back and forth between her friends
when suddenly one of the creatures is
visible in plain sight behind one of
them it's a perfect jump scare and
ratchets the fear present in the film
exponentially home-invasion few modern
horror films have been as acclaimed as
it follows a tense film about a girl
being relentlessly pursued by a creature
that takes the form of other humans
it's a brilliantly simple premise for a
horror film and it works extremely well
but the home invasion sequence is easily
the film standout moment the creature
which can only be seen by protagonist
Jay arrives at Jay's house where she and
her friends are posted up in hopes of
capitalizing on strengthen numbers
the creature appears she springs into a
panic locking herself in her room only
to soon be joined by her friends and an
unusually tall man behind them its
founder and the image it takes this time
is one of the most disturbing forms it
takes in the film we all float before it
was the unstoppable box-office force of
2017 it was a lower budget affair
showcasing a tour de force performance
by Tim Curry as penny wise the dancing
clown the remake is an exceptional piece
of horror but when comparing how each
film adapted the most iconic moment from
the novel they're both based on the
original is head and shoulders above a
new version it comes down to Curry's
performance he takes penny wises
demeanor in a direction that somehow
feels even fresher today than it did in
1990
everything he says feels so so really
out of place that the audience can't
help but feel creeped out
it's all tied together with the infamous
final shot of Penny wises true form
seeping through yellowed fangs and
inhuman eyes it created a generation of
kids who are still afraid of clowns to
this day and this scene is what started
it all thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]